bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition de parlement hebdo en
compagnie d'autres moracchini bonjour
regarde le film bonjour à tous nous
allons donc repasser l'actualité
politique et parlementaire de la semaine
en revue à commencer par la polémique
qui n'en finit plus après les propos du
ministre de l'intérieur claude guéant
sur les civilisations qui ne se valent
pas tout c'est l'assemblée nationale qui
s'enflamme
mardi le député apparenté socialiste de
martinique serge letchimy provoquent le
départ du gouvernement de l'hémicycle
après avoir évoqué le nazisme et les
camps de concentration une usine
flambant neuf au maroc pour renault
voilà de quoi relancer le débat sur les
délocalisations avec des critiques qui
fusent dans la majorité comme dans
l'opposition françois bayrou le candidat
à la présidentielle du modem chantre du
made in france parle de drame pour notre
pays
au chapitre de la présidentielle nicolas
sarkozy de plus en plus candidats dans
une interview au figaro magazine le
président de la république passe à la
vitesse supérieure ils vendent ces
valeurs pour la france et lance l'idée
d'un référendum sur les indemnités des
chômeurs les reer est avec nous pour
commenter cette actualité de la semaine
marielle de sarnez bonjour merci d'être
avec nous sur ce plateau vous êtes
députée européenne vice présidente du
modem et directrice de campagne de
françois bayrou l'était déjà en 2007
vous l'étiez déjà en 2002 dont google
pas en 2002 alors en 2007
première question peut-être sur les
sondages après avoir monté en flèche au
mois de décembre est une sorte de
stagnation ce moral non 13 ce matin 14
hier je trouve que tout c'est pas mal
contenue alors quels termes choisir des
espèces de connivence monopolistique
médiatique deux du parti socialiste un
côté de l'ump de l'autre qui évidemment
voilà monopolis privatise la sphère
d'expression médiatise d'ailleurs j'ai
saisi le csa qui lui même a constaté
qu'ils avaient 15
une monopolisation par deux candidats de
l'espace médiatique et qui alerte et les
chaînes alors je vais rester extrêmement
vigilante
je pense que les français ont droit au
pluralisme dans cette campagne dans les
sondages non non je suis pas là comme il
a pris trois points il ya matin pour
passer à 14
il est à 13 et garage à nous donc c'est
pas un creux voilà nous risquons va
recommencer à monter oui bien sûr que
oui parce que je ne doute pas que les
français d'abord se laisserons pas
imposer le choix qu'on essaye de leur
balancer tous les jours comme ça l'an 10
ans a coûté le premier tour a déjà eu
lieu
circulez ya rien à voir on a d'ores et
déjà les candidats deuxième tour au fond
c'est pas du tout ce que les français
attendent
et donc je suis extrêmement confiante
ils veulent un autre choix ils veulent
un autre changement
ils sont bien que françois bayrou peut
leur apporter les réponses sont dans une
période de creux tout va bien donc
d'accord par rapport à 2007 cette
campagne elle est plus difficile cette
année de laisser piquer dans un état
plus difficile qu'en 2007 et c'est ça
qui nous soucie c'est ça le souci de
françois bayrou tout à fait justifié
tout ce qu'il avait dit sur la dette sur
le déficit depuis 2002 en 2002 françois
bayrou propose la règle d'or si on avait
écouté on n'en serait pas là aujourd'hui
et donc c'est le pays qui est dans une
situation de crise très lourde très très
grave
10% de chômage c'est quelque chose qui
peut déstabiliser une société tout
entière
allez on passe au lundi nicolas sarkozy
angela merkel qui ne se quittent plus
maintenant la main sur le perron de
l'élysée côte à côte lors d'un entretien
télévisé la relation entre angela merkel
et nicolas sarkozy est au beau fixe
le chef de l'état manifestement ravi du
soutien que lui a apporté la chancelière
à l'occasion d'un conseil des ministres
franco allemand
un coup de pouce électorale attendue et
annoncée par l'elysée depuis plusieurs
jours mario lefebvre
c'est un tandem désormais bien rodée il
multiplie les conférences de presse
commune et pour la première fois nicolas
sarkozy et angela merkel participent
ensemble à un entretien télévisé
un couple uni à l'écran la chancelière a
officiellement annoncé son soutien au
président futur candidat et a par le
passé lui m'a apporté son soutien il est
donc tout naturel que je le soutienne
également lors de cette campagne
quand quelqu'un que vous pour qu'ils
vous aient de l'amitié et vous admirez
dit je soutiens l'action qui est la
vôtre
ça me fait plaisir pour autant les
allemands choisissent librement les
français choisissent librement et nous
sommes ici pour faire notre devoir
les deux dirigeants sont à l'unisson ils
prônent la convergence défendre le
traité européen angela merkel balaye
toute renégociation interrogé sur
françois hollande à la chancelière a
fait comprendre qu'elle n'était pas très
pressé de le recevoir
équité rien n'est encore décidé mais le
président de la république n'avait pas
non plus reçu monsieur j't'en maillard
nous prenons nos décisions en fonction
des circonstances
en ce moment nous avons d'autres
problèmes à régler mais le parti
socialiste confirme et persiste il a
lancé une invitation à la chancelière
afin de rencontrer le candidat hollande
avant l'élection lorsque vous pensez que
c'est un bon calcul politique d'afficher
le soutien de la chancelière allemande
de la part de nicolas sarkozy
je vais essayer de m'en tenir aux
principes moi je ne sais pas je pense
que sarkozy fait sans doute des calculs
politiques mais c'est pas ça la question
la question c'est une question de
principe
quand que l'américaine entre patronne de
la télé ou bien éventuellement soutenir
nicolas sarkozy dans un meeting c'est
son choix c'est leur choix
au spa un choix que je ferais mais enfin
après tout c'est leur affaire
mais qu'elle vienne comme chancelière à
l'elysée dans une visite officielle et
en même temps faire au fond de la
propagande sarkozyste un mélange des
genres qui est absolument condamnable et
que je condamne qui n'est pas sain et là
aussi c'est des questions au fond de
principes démocratiques je trouve qu'ils
sont pas bien ton nom revient quand même
à cette idée de calculs politiques en
parlent et delphine il ya un côté
premier de la classe évidemment du bon
élève allemand est ce que ça peut pas un
peu agacé parfois justement il ya
seulement c'est donc à lui que juifs que
font elles vient comme ça dans cette
campagne dire je soutiens nicolas
sarkozy alors évidemment ça ça montre
l'hypocrisie qui l'y a expliqué depuis
des semaines et des mois nicolas sarkozy
n'est pas candidat qui n'est pas en
campagne qui fait son job de président
de la république on voit bien que tout
ça est évidemment complètement faux donc
ça met à mal cette imposture on faut en
terme de communication qui se déclare la
semaine par un oui enfin d'avancer c'est
qu'il est candidat depuis des semaines
et des semaines et des semaines et que
tout ça c'est encore le problème
d'inéquité à propos du buzzer
franco-allemand vous qui êtes députée
européenne comment est perçue cette
hégémonie du couple franco-allemand ch
c'est pas une hégémonie du tout du
couple franco allemand réuni au fond ce
qui était une présidence de l'allemagne
si on regarde les choses telles qu'elles
se passent 1 on voit bien que
l'allemagne à un discours sur l'europe a
les opinions sur l'europe
mangez pas les mêmes enfin au moins ils
ont leur propre discours et leur propre
opinion et qu'en face la france apparaît
on va dire allez un peu faible sans
porter vraiment de message européen ou
de conception de l'idée européenne qui
est la nôtre nous ne connaissons pas la
position française au fond sur l'europe
que nous voulons nous connaissons la
position allemande
donc c'est une relation que je trouve
déséquilibrés
on a besoin d'une relation franco
allemande mais on a besoin qu'elles
soient équilibrés ce n'est pas le cas on
a entendu dans le sujet un françois
hollande a lui aussi sollicité un
entretien auprès d'angela merkel est ce
que françois bayrou
des contacts outre-rhin ce que lui aussi
est là des comptables depuis toujours et
avec angela merkel avec wolfgang
schauble
mais je trouve que l'idée comme ça te
dire il faut absolument aller voir la
chancelière
pendant l'élection présidentielle
française est pour moi je trouve quelque
chose que je trouve un peu étrange c'est
à dire qu'on peut pas critiquer d'une
part le fait qu'angela merkel viennent
soit dans la campagne présidentielle
française et fasse de la publicité au
président sortant
et puis réclamé comme ça de l'avoir
parce qu'on aurait besoin voilà de son
de son soutien implicite à quelque chose
d'acquis qui est étrange pour moi
françois bayrou s'il était telus
soutiendrait le traité européen tel
qu'il a été alors valoir si ce traité
est ratifié
et si un traité ratifié à 25 pays
évidemment c'est difficile de tout
mettre à bas alors est-ce que ce traité
et mal inspirés est-ce qu'on pourrait
s'en passer
moi je pense qu'on pourrait s'en passer
à des coûts font la discipline
budgétaire parce que c'est ça dont il
est question dans le traité il y à des
traités président qui se disait valéry
giscard d'estaing
il a coûté bien franchement il y allait
traiter précédentes ont fixé des règles
notamment l'arrêt du 3%
appliquons les règles alors je vois bien
qu'on essaye de faire de la politique
avec ce traité si ce traité est ratifié
par tout le monde pour redire ce qu'on
dit depuis 30 ans à savoir appliquons
les règles
bon c'est pas forcément très bien
inspiré il n'y a pas de drame non plus
mais il va falloir repenser au rôle de
l'europe dans les mois et les années qui
viennent et au message que la france
soit à l'europe et au monde et de ce
point de vue là je dois dire
qu'aujourd'hui je suis pas satisfaite de
cette absence de message est bien passé
au mardi maintenant quand la
civilisation façon claude guéant fait
beaucoup de bruit dans l'hémicycle
c'est donc une phrase relevée au cours
du précédent week-end le ministre de
l'intérieur qui affirme devant les
étudiants de l'uni syndicat très marqué
à droite que toutes les civilisations ne
se valent pas en ce mardi c'est un
député apparenté socialiste qui va mener
la charge
pas vraiment en douceur c'est mathilde
terrier qui nous le raconte ce week end
c'est lui qui provoqué la polémique avec
ses civilisations un dérapage sémantique
contrôlée qui vient d'être chassé par un
autre vous monsieur guéant vous
privilégiez l'ombre vous nous ramenez
jour après jour à ces idéologies
européennes qui ont donné naissance aux
camps de concentration au bout du long
chapelet est avalisée coloniale monsieur
guéant
régime nazi 6,6 yeux de publication mais
je voulais la civilisation
mes chers collègues rapport au social
rage de dents la colonisation
on se casse une mission civilisatrice et
l'actrice shirley chan wook une force
obscure qui cultive la nostalgie ne
s'était pas que chacun des sims et le
gym et danse a dit monsieur lemay lisait
relations avec le parlement indignés les
membres du gouvernement le premier
ministre en tête quitte l'hémicycle
suspension de séance
pas accepter que la manière dont tu te
poses la question soit une manière qui
insultent toute une population et tout
toute une civilisation pour reprendre
l'expression qui était utilisé voilà
pourquoi je crois que les choses sont
claires la majorité sorti quelques
minutes plus tard la séance reprend je
vous demande monsieur le président
d'exiger de la part de ce parlementaire
et de sa formation politique
des excuses publiques immédiates si nous
n'assistions pas chaque semaine à des
provocations réitérée du ministre de
l'intérieur ne cela ne conduirait pas à
des grâces et des dégradations d'un
climat que l'on ne peut que regretter le
président de l'assemblée considère
l'incident comme grave
il sera donc examinée par le bureau le
14 février alors marielle de sarnez
l'hiérarchie des civilisations contre
camp de concentration au concours des
petites phrases malheureuses qui est le
gagnant
je voudrais être deux choses la première
c'est que je pense que les
téléspectateurs qui regardent les
questions d'actualité qui ont l'habitude
de la gare dès le mardi et mercredi
moi je pense qu'ils sont consternés
quand ils voient ça c'est quand ils
voient les gens hurlaient d'un beau et
d'un autre se levait partir
tout ça n'est pas sérieux tout ça n'est
pas raisonnable je trouve c'est un
parlement qui dysfonctionnent que ça ne
va pas et qu'au fond notre pays mérite
c'est mieux et que notre démocratie
mériterait mieux et que la crise qui est
là en france mériterait de la part de
nos parlementaires
des comportements on va dire plus
responsable plus apaisée plus
constructif et c'est tout cela que nous
voulons changer avec françois bayrou
cette espèce de caricature de la
démocratie dans laquelle on à la droite
la gauche chacun crispé sur leur idée je
vais venir c'est la question que ses
frasques et qui s'affrontent
il ya quelque chose là dedans qui est
pour moi est tout à fait à rejeter c'est
pas la démocratie au parlement dont
jaurès comme le groupe socialiste ne
devait par ailleurs après je vais
revenir sur le fond si vous voulez bien
déjà sur la forme ce choc c'est très
représentatif d'une démocratie
parlementaire qui ne va pas qui ne
fonctionne pas et d'un parlement qu'il
faudra profondément réformée réformer
dans sa pluralité la représentation des
parlementaires qui est en fait
confisquer par quand même ump et ps
ils font 50 % des voix ils ont 95% des
sièges ça ne va pas cette espèce
d'affrontements permanent ce n'est pas
constructif pour la france c'est la
première chose que je voulais dire
deuxièmement les propos de claude guéant
je les condamne de toutes mes forces je
les trouve plus que mal inspiré je les
trouve dangereux
j'ai tout dangereux parce que le monde
dans lequel on vit est un monde qui
n'est pas facile qui est dangereux
jallet répéter le terme et dans lequel
stigmatiser ou montrer du doigt une
simulation groupe de personnes ou un
pays des pays
c'est exactement le contraire de ce
qu'il faut on a besoin au fond de
pacification on a besoin de recherche de
paix et pas de recherche d'affrontement
en violences dans le monde et chez nous
en france et que cette manière de
montrer du doigt l'islam parce que c'est
ça dont il s'agit bien c'est
déstabilisant pour le monde et c'est
déstabilisant chez nous en france
si l'arrêt et donc je condamne répété il
a un port du député balla première
partie de sa réponse
on comprend bien tout va bien puis après
il dérape et ceci n'est pas une bonne
chose parce que les mots ont un sens et
qu'il faut faire attention d'utiliser
tous ces mots par exemple de nazisme de
concentration je veux dire faisons
attention à tout ça c'est évidemment un
dérapage et la hausse il ne sert pas la
démocratie mais ce que départ vous
pensez que le client est en mission
commandée par un connaisseur qu'il y a
station une partie de l'électorat des
jeunes lorsqu'il ya une aspiration
global visiblement puisque son la
retrouve aujourd'hui dans l'interview du
figaro magazine
c'était un peu le discours de dakar
c'est à dire qu'il ya des ordres de
civilisation il est des civilisations
supérieur aux meilleurs que d'autres
je pense exactement l inverse je pense
qu'il ya des évolutions politiques qu'il
faut évidemment condamné et qu'on peut
condamner mais je pense que on n'a pas à
hiérarchiser les civilisations je trouve
ce discours est extrêmement dangereux
pour le monde dans lequel nous allons
vivre dans lequel nos enfants vont vivre
donc oui je trouve qu'il ya une
inspiration qui ne sont pas très bons
donc c'était pas un dérapage c'est est
et non jaune en terre je crois que ce
sont des choses malheureusement qu'on a
déjà entendu et je vois bien qu avec
l'interview de nicolas sarkozy on a le
sentiment que cette espèce de course
comme ça des thématiques qui sont à la
droite de la droite de la droite
il ya quelque chose là dedans qui me
révolte et ça n'est pas au fond la
culture et la tradition de la droite
française moi je suis au centre mais la
droite même chiraquienne d'hyères où la
droite d'avant-hier pompidou chabat
enfin bref le à perdre iea d'avant-hier
ça n'était pas ça non plus allez on
continue une actualité de la semaine la
sécurité ce n'est pas seulement
l'apanage de la droite c'est ce qu'a
voulu montrer françois hollande lors
d'un déplacement à dijon
accompagné par monsieur justice et
monsieur sécurité les sénateurs ps andré
vallini et françois rebsamen
le candidat socialiste à la
présidentielle a détaillé ses
propositions notamment pour lutter
contre ce qu'il appelle les petits caïds
on écoute je veux que les réponses
soient apportées à porter pour régler la
délinquance des mineurs apportés pour
que les quartiers ne soient pas soumises
aux trafiquants aux petits caïds
nous mettrons un peu plus de moyens un
peu plus d'effectifs ne l'ait
redéploieront nous serons sortis plus
d'établissements pour accueillir les
mineurs délinquants et nous ferons en
sorte que dans les quartiers
il y ait une présence qui permettent de
rassurer
servette on a beaucoup entendu françois
bayrou sur l'emploi l'endettement
l'école un petit peu moins sur la
sécurité alors quelles sont ses réponses
sécurité c'est simple je vois françois
hollande parle de la question des moyens
je crois qu'il faut arrêter de se
raconter qu'on va régler tous les
problèmes de la société française en
dépensant davantage d'argent il va
falloir qu'on gère mieux va falloir que
peut-être on replace un peu les
questions badia de droit de liberté
individuelle de libertés publiques dans
le débat politique français va falloir
qu'on replace la question aussi je
trouve de l'effectivité de la peine et
la rapidité de la paix notamment pour
les mineurs et de l'exemplarité de la
peine
toutes les questions de travaux
d'intérêts généraux par exemple parce
que je trouve qu'il y a quelques fois
une sur pénalisation c'est à dire que
vous faut mettre dans des maisons
d'arrêt où en es prison c'est pas
forcément la bonne solution lors celui
qui commet le premier délit
donc là je crois qu'il ya un travail
vraiment amener justice police ensemble
d'une façon apaisée
non je n'ai pas en visionnaire mais ça
n'est pas vrai ça ne se fera pas où ça
ne se ferait pas si françois hollande
était élu
on raconte des histoires en français va
pas embaucher des policiers de plus les
enseignants de plus ça n'est pas
possible
la question demain ça va être comme en
fait des économies et comment on les
fait de façon le plus juste la plus
juste la plus équitable et sans toucher
au fond aux responsabilités régaliennes
de l'état ce qu'il doit assumer
l'état doit assumer la sécurité et je
crois pour ça il faut se garder de
rentrer dans des débats sécurité de
droite de gauche il y à des questions
qui doit faire l'objet d'un consensus
national
la sécurité est une question qui doivent
allonger la consultation la lente ou de
moyens oui mon doit arrêter non écoutez
on n'a pas arrêté de mettre des moyens
on à 56 % des dépenses publiques en
france aujourd'hui on est le pays
d'europe dans lequel la dépense publique
est le plus haut
me dites pas que dans les pays je ne
sais pas moi scandinaves ou chez nos
voisins on règle moins bien les
questions par exemple ayant trait à la
sécurité
il va falloir mieux gérer avoir de
meilleures stratégies faire confiance
aux hommes qui sont sur le terrain faire
respecter quelques principes et sortir
ces questions-là des débats de politique
partisane
moi je suis très frappé juste un mot de
voir que chaque
année on a le débat sur les chiffres de
la sécurité qui sortent sains que ce
soit un ministère de l'intérieur de
droite ou amis celle de gauche les
autres disent bon sortons sa de la
sphère on va dire partisane rendons aux
citoyens la vérité sur ce qui se passe
en matière de sécurité dans le pays
faisons le de façon impartiale ça c'est
très important aussi à le replacer au
mercredi avec la fameuse tva sociale qui
arrive en commission à l'assemblée
nicolas sarkozy l'avait annoncé le
gouvernement l'a fait le collectif
budgétaire est examiné ce mercredi matin
en conseil des ministres avant
d'atterrir devant la commission des
finances de l'assemblée
au menu bien sûr la fameuse tva sociale
qui permettra un allègement des charges
des entreprises
chloé buffard en conseil des ministres
ce matin le dernier collectif budgétaire
du quinquennat deux mesures phares tva
sociale et taxe sur les transactions
financières censée relancer l'économie
nous n'avons pas besoin d'un troisième
plan de rigueur contrairement à ce que
présente prétendaient certains cassandre
pourquoi d'abord parce que nous
recueillons les fruits de notre bonne
gestion 2011 avec une baisse du déficit
de l'état
supérieur de 4 milliards et demi à ce
qui était attendu cela n'impacte positif
et mécanique de 3 6 milliards d'euros en
moins de déficit sur l'année 2012 dans
la foulée valérie pécresse et françois
baroin sont auditionnés par les députés
de la commission des finances
le calendrier est très serré l'examen du
texte doit débuter lundi prochain à
l'assemblée pour une adoption définitive
fin février début mars au plus tard
mais c'est seulement huit mois après le
1er octobre que la hausse de la tva
devrait être effective le collectif
budgétaire prévoit une augmentation de
la tva et de la csg pour financer
l'allégement des charges patronales
l'objectif du gouvernement baisser le
coût du travail et relancer la
compétitivité de l'industrie mais à
gauche on dénonce
une baisse du pouvoir d'achat françois
hollande a déjà prévenu s'il est élu il
annulera la tva sociale
vous avez réagi marielle de sarnez un
sujet aux propos optimistes ne valérie
pécresse ne sont pas des propos
optimistes je sais pas dans quel pays
helvig dans quel monde vit jeudi il faut
arrêter de raconter des histoires et des
krachs aux français jeudi à c'est très
important de ce seuil est au moins de
cette période de la campagne
présidentielle pour leur dire la vérité
sur l'état du pays
et moi je demande que valérie pécresse
lisent avec attention le rapport de la
cour des comptes qui viennent de sortir
qui dément chacun de ces propos qu'ils
énoncent j'attends d'un déficit - un fil
des manches chacune de ses phrases que
ça soit sur ce qu'on a appelé les plans
de rigueur français qui étaient en fait
en un brouillon sans aucune visibilité
sans aucune visibilité le rapport de la
cour des comptes le rappel qui dément
l'idée que tout irait très bien madame
la marquise chez nous mais c'est
absolument faux et moi je crois que dire
la vérité
c'est la première étape nécessaire pour
redresser un pays vous n'arriverez pas à
dresser le pays en tous les cas c'est ça
que françois bayrou fera dans cette
campagne présidentielle sans affronter
la vérité et sans dire les choses telles
qu'elles sont sur la tva sociale est ce
que françois bayrou annulerez lui aussi
c'est françois hollande a dit qu'il
annulerait la mise en place de la tva
sociale bord je trouve que toute cette
façon de faire comme ça au dernier
moment deux mois avant une élection
n'est pas une bonne façon de gouverner
c'est pas comme ça qu'on entraîne la
confiance on regrette la confiance en
prenant des décisions sur le long terme
et pas dans la précipitation alors ça
c'est important un problème heures en
nos méthodes
c'est pas que ça me fasse pas peur c'est
qu'on a une dette et qu'on a un déficit
et que si on se met pas le comble est
sérieusement ce déficit va nous
rattraperont pas comme un métronome
elles ont augmenté et que donc s'il ya
une augmentation d'un point de la tva
nous nous l'affecteront impôts déficit
et pourquoi pas en 2014 pourquoi pas en
2014 sauf si sauf si bonne nouvelle la
croissance est au rendez-vous ce qu'on
peut toujours en tous les cas espérer en
tous les cas agir pour messi un point de
tva supplémentaires il sera affecté pour
nous au déficit
merci espère que la tva sociale et donc
la baisse des cotisations familiales
permettra la création de cent mille
emplois ce que c'est réaliste un slogan
non c'est complètement bidon ça et je
veux dire on va pas c'est pas le coût du
travail qui est pénalisant en france le
coût du travail en france contrairement
à ce qu'on raconte tous les jours c'est
à peu près le même qu'en allemagne
donc on va pas d'abord commencé à falla
baisse ou coût du travail parce que je
peux vous dire que les chinois les
indiens ou les habitants du bangladesh
serons toujours devant nous un en termes
de faible coût du travail et donc ceci
n'a aucun sens deuxièmement si on
voulait baisser mais colossalement le
coût du travail bien il faudrait une
augmentation de 5 points de tva vous
disent tous les spécialistes parce qu'il
faudra enlever 35 milliards de charges
et donc ça veut dire cinq pales télé a
évidemment ceci est absolument
irréaliste
ce qu'il faut c'est produire enfin c'est
toute la thématique de la campagne de
françois bayrou salue rendre de l'emploi
aux français on a eu les chiffres du
commerce extérieur cette semaine qu'ils
sont consternants 60 milliards de
déficit en france et aux environs de 160
milliards d'excédents en allemagne en
suisse et coûté 160 jeudi un voilage
était pas très loin par dont 158
écoutez on a les mêmes on est dans la
même sphère européenne
nous avons la même monnaie qui s'appelle
l'euro et bien d'un côté il ya un pays
qui a su ce redouter d'un appareil
industriel et qui fait de la production
de qualité l'autre côté un pays qui
s'appauvrit depuis dix ans et bien c'est
ça à quoi nous devons dire stop et c'est
ça un des enjeux majeurs de la campagne
des élections présidentielles qui va
s'ouvrir bientôt je l'espère avec tous
ses acteurs
alors tous les efforts 1 présentée dans
le collectif budgétaire sont ils
suffisants on a eu cette semaine
l'avis de la cour des comptes sur la
question son président didier migaud est
venu présenter à l'assemblée puis au
sénat le rapport annuel
il demande un effort accru au
gouvernement actuel et à venir sur la
réduction des niches fiscales mais
surtout la diminution des dépenses
publiques on écoute la perte
considérable des marges de manoeuvre que
la charge de la dette nous impose
aujourd'hui et pourrait nous imposer
davantage demain si nous ne mettons pas
en oeuvre un redressement rapide de nos
comptes montre qu'en effet afin de
rester maître de sa souveraineté un pays
doit être maître de ses finances
publiques
finalement didier migaud est à peu près
sur la même ligne avec françois bayrou
ils pensent la même chose je signe des
deux mains
c'est une convergence des hommes
honnêtes ou faut qu'ils regardent la
situation avec honnêteté et impartialité
ce qui est le cas de la cour des comptes
et ce qui est le cas aussi de françois
bayrou et c'est pour ça que ça converge
donc on l'a vu à la cour des comptes
tire la sonnette d'alarmé
il faut absolument réduire le déficit
public le gouvernement se donne comme
date butoir 2016 françois hollande 2015
françois bay allait pas vrai c'est dans
de longs mois ce sont des mots ce sont
des phrases quand françois hollande dit
va revenir à l'équilibré de quelles
économies y parle et ce qu'il dit à un
moment il faudra dépenser moins non il
dit contraire il faudra dépenser plus et
quand la droite l'ump dit bien sûr on
est en train de revenir à l équilibre
des finances publiques
de quoi parlent-ils il augmente les
prélèvements mais ce qu'ils ont parlé
d'une seule économie réelle sur le
budget de la nation la réponse est non
alors on vous fait des jolies phrases
ont fait des belles phrases mais elle
trompe personne et moi je préfère que
autour et avec françois bayrou on
regarde ces choses là les yeux grands
ouverts
on se disent que oui on peut arriver oui
on peut au fond s'y coller à ces efforts
là de façon juste et que si on ne fait
pas c'est de l'extérieur comme nous
imposera les choses il faut que ce
serait bien que ce soit les français qui
le décide il faut quand même trouver 115
milliards de il faut 500 milliards
d'euros
nous nous proposons de faire 50
milliards d'économie sur trois années où
trois années et demi et 50 milliards de
recettes supplémentaires il faudrait 100
milliardaires c'est l'impôt donc on nous
sommes les seuls
nous sommes les seuls à donner ces
chiffres là un et à être absolument
qu'elle est ce le rapport de la cour des
comptes et moi j'attends que françois
hollande et nicolas sarkozy nous dise un
mot réel de sa pas des phrases pour
faire semblant
mais la réalité des choses et je serai
très
heureuse qu'il nous rejoigne une
opposition et je serai très heureuse
qu'ils disent oui françois bayrou a
raison il a raison nous devons nous y
coller parce qu'il faudra bien que dans
le rassemblement que je souhaite que
françois bayrou perd le plus large
possible et bien au fond cette idée que
nous devons faire face à notre dette le
déficit pour le bien-être de nous-mêmes
et de nos enfants que cette idée
s'impose dans la campagne zéro
augmentation des dépenses publiques
pendant deux ans et celle des pensions
des retraites et des salaires
bien sûr allez on va passer au jeudi
avec vous allez être contents puisque
vous vouliez une mise en place de tous
les candidats m avec un président qui
lui est de plus en plus candidats c'est
clair et nicolas sarkozy a choisi le
figaro magazine pour une interview sur
le thème des valeurs le président
propose un référendum sur les demandeurs
d'emploi et se demandent s'il en foudre
est un également sur les procédures
d'expulsion alors pour ceux qui
douteraient encore de sa candidature
tout cela ressemble fort à des premiers
thèmes de campagne germain andrieu c'est
une interview du président qui ressemble
au programme d'un candidat travail
responsabilité autorités trois mots clés
d'une future campagne articulée autour
des valeurs opposées au mariage
homosexuel à l'euthanasie et au droit de
vote des étrangers
le président presque candidats visent
clairement l'électorat de droite
toujours dans le programme de référendum
sont envisagées l'un sur le droit des
étrangers
l'autre sur les chômeurs là encore rien
ne sera fait avant le prochain
quinquennat le grand référendum c'est
l'élection présidentielle et on donne
ses idées dans une élection
présidentielle ont dit ces propositions
là il y a surtout d'après ce que je vois
ce que je comprend une volonté
supplémentaires d'avoir des débats qui
divisent
la méthode sarkozy s'est à chaque fois
qu'il a faits divers on fait une loi est
là c'est sur des sujets qui sont
complexes qui divise profondément les
français eh bien on fait un référendum
c'est du populisme c'est un clin d'oeil
aux électeurs de madame le pen
l'objectif avoué consulter l'opinion des
français sur le système d'indemnisation
du chômage sur le droit ou non des
chômeurs de refuser un travail ou une
formation
reste à entrer en campagne pour calmer
l'impatience des militants et des élus
la réalité c'est comment je peux
aujourd'hui répondre le mieux aux
préoccupations de mes concitoyens si ce
n'est en est consultant et là il a tout
à fait raison à l'heure après qu'ont pu
s'attacher cela un programme de campagne
pourquoi pas pour le moment la majorité
multiplie les annonces les écrans de
fumée pour conserver la surprise
dernière rumeur en date une déclaration
de candidature dès la semaine prochaine
autour du 16 février avec à la clé un
premier meeting à marseille
alors avant de vous faire réagir sur le
fond sur cette candidature imminente
sûrement la semaine prochaine avec
meeting le 19 février à marseille c'est
une bonne nouvelle il faut vraiment
qu'ils se déclare je sais pas si c'est
une bonne nouvelle ça surfrance
étrangers oui et que les médias c'est
complètement bidon tout ça disons les
choses tout le monde voit bien que
nicolas sarkozy est en campagne depuis
des semaines et des semaines et des
semaines lors de voilà alors ça veut
dire quoi que au lieu que son temps de
parole soit pas content et qui sera
davantage compter qu'au lieu de se
servir des moyens de l'état il s'en
servir un peu moins enfin bon et encore
on verra
bon voilà ceci éclaircie une situation
qui était connu par tous les français
mais cette non candidat sion a laissé un
peu plus espace à françois bayrou n'ont
jusqu'à présent écouter est-ce qu'on
peut revenir sur le fond si vous voulez
bien parce qu il ya un vrai jeu oui
parce que vous parlez des espaces je
trouve ça absolument consternants cette
espèce de course comme ça on a
l'impression à des thématiques et d'un
autre temps et je trouve ça dangereux on
dit c'est la droite et la droite c'est
pas ça je veux dire il ya une droite
républicaine en france
social
tolérante et ouverte qui ne va pas se
reconnaître dans ce type de revêtement
l'édition et un référendum sur les
demandeurs d'emploi mais c'est d'une
mois je trouve ça terrible ça veut dire
quoi qu'on montre du doigt les
demandeurs d'emploi qu'on dit attention
là il faudrait arrêter avec le
traitement social du chômage mais vous
croyez que les chômeurs les jeunes
chômeuses et les jeunes chômeurs
d'aujourd'hui qui est un bts en poche et
qui trouvent pas d'emploi je crois
qu'ils sont pas qu'ils n'ont pas
d'emploi qui sont au chômage par plaisir
vous croyez pas que la priorité urgente
d'un pays c'est pas simplement de leur
rendre de l'emploi de leur donner de
l'emploi à la caisse gérer les entrées
mission du référendum n'est pas futile
indemniser les chômeurs un set il faut
qu'ils acceptent que les ivoiriens vous
ne visez pas oui ça revient exactement
sa s'est alliée jeu sous-entend que il
pourrait y avoir un problème est qu'au
fond les chômeurs s'ils restent au
chômage c'est bien parce qu'ils le
veulent
parce qu'on leur en propose des emplois
mais vous voyez bien ils les prennent
pas alors il faut que tout ça ça suffit
et bien moi je trouve ça consternant et
je sais que la france ça n'est pas ça et
que les français dans leur immense
majorité rejetteront tout ceci ce n'est
pas une manière de gouverner le pays
vous gouvernez pas le pays
en ciblant comme ça en mettant le doigt
sur une partie des français et en love
les soumettant à une espèce de jugement
de valeur que je trouve absolument
terrible l'urgence pour les chômeurs
c'est de leur rendre l'emploi
c'est encore un exemple l'allemagne
visiblement où la bourse a l'exemple
d'allemagne a eu un référendum en
allemagne sont bordées de libéra
mais que vous regardiez rendre
obligatoire vous regardiez le premier
regard ces sujets qui sont complexes
coûté rendre obligatoire le fait que à
la première offre d'emploi vous devez la
prendre on arrête de vous donner des
indemnités pour lesquels je vous
rappelle vous avez cotisé quand vous
avez travaillé je dit juste ça en
passant un vous avez cotisé pour vos
indemnités
c'est pas du vol jeudi on vous les
doigts alors ça veut dire que on vous
propose un emploi même s'il n'est pas
correspond pas à vos compétences
est ce que vous savez faire ou à vos
envies si vous ne prenez pas vous êtes
disqualifié pour avoir des allocations
de chômage
mais dans quel pays serions nous si nous
mettrions ça si nous mettions ça en
oeuvre demain ce site et pas la france
est ce si les français n'en voudront pas
avec ces annonces en voit un nicolas
sarkozy voudrait multiplier le recours
au référendum c'est également ici c'est
un virage très à droite je crois que le
référendum peut être important pour les
questions on va dire lourde du pays
par exemple le retour à l'équilibré des
finances publiques
c'est quelque chose qu'on peut tout à
fait imaginer de mettre autour de la
table tous ceux que cela concerne
surtout quand il faudra décider
d'efforts communs et d'efforts partagés
à condition qu'il soit équitable et au
fond pour l'ancrer dans la
responsabilité française pourquoi pas le
soumettre à référendum je pense aux
retraites
je pense à une réforme des institutions
ça oui
ce type de grand réformes sont des
questions importantes mais sur ce genre
de questions
soit la question des chômeurs soit la
question j'ai vu aussi peut-être
concernant les immigrés vous voyez bien
que c'est pour faire flamber la société
française autour de débats sans fin et
que c'est à mon avis les le contraire de
ce qu'il faut faire
cette société elle a besoin qu'on la
rassemblent qu'on l'a mobilise cola
mobilisent pour l'emploi c'est
exactement le contraire de l'adema voir
marine de sarnez dans cette campagne qui
n'a pas encore commencé
une droite qui est bien marqué à droite
et finalement françois hollande qui est
marquée à gauche françois bayrou
je trouve ça très bien ça va être très
intéressant je préférais que nicolas
sarkozy n'ait pas ses propos imaginant
imaginons que les deux grands candidats
soient tous les deux au deuxième tour
françois chose je ne vais pas imaginer
ça parce que je sais bien que tout est
fait pour ça je sais bien qu'ils aient
une espèce ont mal y est allé d'entendre
cordiale 1 entre sarkozy hollande pour
au fond préempter le débat politique
je pars je te réponds puis je te parle
puis je vais te répondre
ils vont essayer de nous caser sa de
nous faire ça pendant les semaines et
les semaines et mois je vous dis ça ne
marchera pas ça ne fonctionnera pas si
françois bayrou n'est pas au second tour
et je vais tout faire et nous allons
tout faire pour que françois bayrou
occupe cet espace central qui demandent
plus que jamais à être occupé françois
hollande comme vous l'avez dit elle fait
une campagne de gauche très bien c'est
son choix
nicolas sarkozy fait une campagne pas de
droite républicaine c'est encore autre
chose là hein
ils courent après des thématiques qui
sont pas bonnes sur le pays
eh bien écoutez tout ceci effectivement
ouvre un espace central dans lequel je
ne doute pas qu'il y aura de nombreux
français nombreuses françaises qu'ils
viennent on va dire de du centre du
centre-droit du centre gauche de la
droite républicaine et sociale des
réformateurs de progrès qui nous
rejoindront je dis toujours
l'inauguration à tanger au maroc d'une
nouvelle usine renault avec cette
inauguration c'est le débat sur la
délocalisation et le coût du travail qui
est relancé
les salariés seront payés 240 euros par
mois alors pour les sénateurs ce jeudi
en séance il organisait un débat sur
l'avenir de l'automobile en france la
pilule est amère flora sauvages
difficile de rivaliser avec les coûts de
production du maroc un pays où le
salaire mensuel s'élève à 250 euros en
moyenne
renault a choisi de délocaliser sa
production de voitures low cost à tanger
une décision qui est peu appréciée au
scénar pour abaisser le coût du travail
et bien on va délocaliser pour un
croître un rendement ouvert envers les
actionnaires que l'on soit de gauche de
droite sur les bancs de la haute
assemblée où on déplore le tournant que
prend renault détenu à 15% par l'état
ce constructeur ne produit plus que 18 à
20% de sa production sur le sol national
il y à du capital public dans renault et
la direction s'apprête à poursuivre
cette politique de délocalisation il
faut que nos grands constructeurs
français est une attitude plus citoyenne
qui ne l'ont aujourd'hui
pour le patron du modem françois bayrou
la décision de renault va à l'encontre
du made in france qui lui est si cher on
a besoin d'avoir chez nous des
productions des emplois des richesses
qui se font le fait que tous s'en aille
que tout fish le temps c'est un drame
pour notre pays
interrogé sur le fait de savoir si cette
délocalisation est une bonne chose
le secrétaire d'état chargé du commerce
extérieur par est embarrassé c'est une
si on réfléchit en termes de d'accès à
des marchés en développement c'est une
bonne chose s'il s'agit de réimporter
les voitures en france
la question est la question est tout à
fait différente aujourd'hui la
production de renault en france n'a
cessé de se réduire comme peau de
chagrin à tanger renault emploiera 6000
salariés dans son usine pour construire
150 mille véhicules par an alors renault
au maroc est ce que c'est un scandale
d'état marie-anne dessins dans tous les
cas l'état n'a pas fait et ne fait pas
son travail d'actionnaires pouvant avoir
une stratégie sur ces grandes questions
d'industrie automobile et renault ne
fait pas correctement son travail
ça c'est une certitude il ne faisant
rien qu'à ce qu'on savait donc pardonnez
moi quand vous avez 15 % vous pouvez
décider de peser en plus il yad autres
on va dire acteurs institutionnels dans
le tour de table
donc si vous mettez acteurs
institutionnels plus c'est à vous pouvez
tout à fait avoir une stratégie
la vérité c'est que là ya pas tratégie
on laisse là les choses on ne décide de
rien il ya aucun volontarisme qui
s'exprime et on constate les choses il y
avait un million deux cent mille
voitures fabriquées en france par
renault dans il y a cinq ans on a
aujourd'hui quatre cent quarante mille
voitures fabriquées dans le même temps
en allemagne le nombre de voitures
fabriquées par bba volkswagen à
augmenter et donc il n'y a pas de
fatalité au fond à produire moins de
voitures ça veut donc dire qu'on a mal
fait notre travail
renault n'a pas bien bossé et les
n'a pas fait son travail quand vous avez
toyota qui vient à valenciennes si
toyota bien à valenciennes c'est
rentable pour toyota
ils viennent pas à juste parce que
valenciennes est une belle ville ils
viennent parce que c'est rentable et que
c'est bon pour eux et donc ça veut dire
qu'on peut produire en france que ça
peut marcher pour l'actionnaire pour
toyota ça marche et que par exemple
quand on voit que nissan qui est associé
à arnaud produits les voitures en europe
partout sauf en france à dire en espagne
ou en grande-bretagne il ya quelque
chose qui ne marche
franchement pas juste avec un smic à 250
euros au maroc on est ravi la course à
la baisse du coût du travail
ça n'a absolument aucun sens on doit
rester nous producteurs si possible
réindustrialiser notre pays ça c'est
l'obsession de françois bâillon et il a
raison c'est la seule façon de rendre de
l'emploi avec des produits de qualité
des produits de qualité et donc de la
recherche de l'innovation
mais il faut arrêter aussi de déserter
au fond l'industriel et l'automobile il
faut suspendre d'être sur les aides
publiques aux entreprises cette année
qu'on dise à droite et gauche confondues
quand la gauche 12 années c'était la
même chose quand la droite gouverne
c'est la même chose ils ne font pas leur
travail
l'état il est actionnaire et donc il
peut définir une stratégie et une
stratégie offensive plutôt d'être
toujours sur la défensive est la seule
stratégie offensive que je connais c'est
effectivement de mettre le paquet sur ce
que françois bayrou appelle le produire
en france
allez marine le salon a terminé avec un
des thèmes fétiches de françois bayroux
l'éducation françois hollande est en
déplacement ce jeudi sur ce thème à
orléans outre la création de 60000
postes
le candidat socialiste annonce un plan
de réforme des rythmes scolaires à la
formation des enseignants
jean baptiste la glace pour parler
d'éducation françois hollande commence
par jouer les professeurs d'histoire il
rend un hommage appuyé à jean zay le
ministre de l'éducation de léon blum
assassiné par la milice en 1944
l'éducation pour françois hollande ce
n'est pas seulement de l'histoire c'est
aussi tes chiffres sa promesse de créer
60 mille postes en 5 ans intègre dans
une réforme globale du système éducatif
je veux une refondation pas une
restauration une refondation de l'école
ces cinq dernières années la france a
perdu beaucoup de temps et de force
nous héritons d'une dette éducative au
même titre qu'il existe une dette
financière
une dette budgétaire et bien il y a une
dette éducative
françois hollande s'est inspiré des pays
nordiques il souhaite concentrer ses
efforts sur la période déterminante de
l'école primaire
son objectif plus d'un professeur par
classe pour mieux accompagner les élèves
qui décrochent le rythme scolaire
devrait être revu fini la semaine de
quatre jours
place à une année scolaire et à des
semaines plus longue mais avec des
journées plus courtes
le candidat socialiste souhaite aussi
rendre moins violente la transition
entre écoles collèges lycées et
enseignement supérieur avec une réforme
de certains programmes
enfin françois hollande s'adresse aussi
aux enseignants il propose une refonte
de leur formation avec la création
d'écoles du professorat et de
l'éducation parlait qu'elle passerait
tous les futurs profs du primaire comme
de l'université françois hollande eux
cèdent à leurs principales
revendications
il rétablira à l'année de stage pour les
apprentis enseignants alors françois
bayrou avait lui-même présenté son
programme sur l'éducation le week end
précédent je vais être un petit peu
provost peut-être si je me rappelle des
enseignants est ce que le programme de
françois hollande n'est pas plus
attractif plus alléchants création de
deux postes n'avait pas lu parce qu'en
france c'est ça le problème
d'abord je veux dire une chose les
enseignants avant d'être des enseignants
sont des citoyens donc au fond c'est
aussi comme citoyens qu'ils vont aller
voter et qu'il sut cette campagne
électorale ça c'est la première chose la
deuxième chose c'est que c'est très
intéressant ce que voulait dire c'est à
dire qu'on est vraiment dans un pays où
on considère qu'on ne peut améliorer les
choses qu'en remettant des moyens et des
moyens et des moyens et de l'argent et
de l'argent et de l'argent nous n'avons
plus d'argent ne manque pas de
profession n'avons plus d'argent non ne
manque pas de professeurs on peut faire
nous nous proposons un françois bayrou
quelque chose qui est absolument juste
c'est de dire dans la période difficile
dans laquelle nous sommes
nous garantissons poste pour poste pour
cinq ans les moyens de l'école
garantissons les moyens l'éducation
nationale nous n'y toucherons pas et ça
je peux vous dire que c'est un beau
cadeau que la nation feu à son école
es sénia normal
et c'est bien normal mais promettent
60000 postes de plus comme si ces
soixante mille postes de plus à les
régler les problèmes de
dysfonctionnement de l'école eh bien ça
ne marchera pas et ça ne se ferait pas
l'école française
elle a dégringolé elle était parmi les
meilleures écoles du monde aujourd'hui
dans classement de l' ocde est entre 20e
25e 30e pour tous l'apprentissage et la
maîtrise des fondamentaux et donc c'est
pas une question de moyens c'est une
question d'organisation du système c'est
une question d' objectif il faut arrêter
d'avoir des phrases général sur l'école
arrêtez de dire je remettrai des moyens
c'est ce qui compte c'est quoi c'est ce
qu'on appelle l'effet m c'est ce qui se
passe dans la classe
alors oui il ya une obsession que
françois bayrou a c'est que par exemple
les plus d'élèves qui passe en sixième
sans maîtriser la lecture et donc nous
disons aux primaires désormais 50% du
temps doit être consacrée à
l'apprentissage du français
ça c'est important parce que ça crée les
conditions pour qu'ils aient plus un
jeune au bord de la route plus tard
alors malheureusement on n'a pas le
temps de développer plus c'est dommage
que vous étiez donc directrice de
cabinet de françois bégaudeau vis à vis
du glacier jax de connu c'est bien mais
malheureusement il en faire qu on se
quitte
merci d'être venus et
delphine au revoir au revoir dit à la
semaine prochaine même lieu même heure
bonne semaine